[Music]
i'm obsessed with the word and versus or
and i'm obsessed with
people
not debating things in board rooms that
normal human beings don't care about
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hi gary how are you doing i'm well
michelle how are you this is our first
[ __ ] yeah fridays
i'm really excited about it
me too me too
um for everybody tuning in because i
know this first episode we're doing on
my linkedin live uh shows one of the
strongest uh entrepreneurs that i've
come across uh in my
journeys and um we've become friendly
and
uh i just really
adore and i'll let her fully introduce
herself to this audience but i adore
what her company and
mission is and what they mean to
the community and we got to yapping kind
of one
outside day in the macro and decided
let's do a show
i know i'm uh i'm so excited to be here
with you and uh i think a lot of i got a
lot of early inspiration from what you
did gary so it's really cool i've been a
serial entrepreneur my whole life
um was lucky enough to join the cast of
the canadian shark tank like seven years
ago and i saw that founders were giving
up way too much of their business uh in
the early stages and then spending most
of that money on ads and inventory and
that didn't make sense and so
through that experience thought there
had to be a better way to do this um me
and andrew introduced this idea of
revenue share financing so we'll give
you you know
anywhere from 10 000 up to 10 million
dollars and instead of taking you know
10 or 20 or 30 of your company that will
own forever we take a percentage of your
revenue until we get our capital back
plus six percent
it's not debt we don't take your
business if you don't pay us back it's
not a loan there's no fixed payment
timelines there's no personal guarantees
and
everyone thought we were [ __ ] nuts
and when we started i think you know we
were in your home city of new york and
250 people on wall street told us we
were crazy at the beginning
but we figured out how to do this in
scale and most importantly we've now
backed more than 6 000 different
founders with over two and a half
billion dollars in capital so this is
not a small thing anymore and our
mission
yeah in
in garyvee simple english talk this is a
financing mechanism that doesn't force
founders to give up so much equity of
their business and isn't predatory
where you know people are getting
screwed and you own their businesses
true really
i like that i love that that's that's as
simple as it gets and it was built on
the fact that andrew and i have both
been ex-founders and we wish there was a
better way to do that and we hope that
this enables anyone with a great idea
knowing that that statement is very
popular and like whoa a lot of people
just got hit like well what is this i
need to if they don't know this
is it is it tough to here's just the
real life question is it tough to meet
the criteria
of getting the financing
no because i'm empathetic to you guys
too like you don't want to be giving out
money to people who can't pay back and
there's a lot of headaches that come
along with that yeah here's the here's
the things we're looking for we're
looking for a minimum of two thousand
dollars a monthly revenue so you can be
very early in your journey and we'll
start funding you then with our
clearangel product um
and we're looking for you know positive
unit economics so as an e-commerce
business if you sell something for 100
bucks you got to have less than you know
100 of ad spend and product cost and so
that is you know should be relevant for
your business no matter what you're
selling uh so it's not hard to get uh to
get started with us and we genuinely
think businesses with great unit
economics that are just starting to
scale are ones that we should be
investing in by the way the other thing
that's really cool about this show is
that we see your comments linkedin so
please say hello let's do age sex
location aol 1995. uh abram good to see
you you're again
eric muzik great to see you
bachman patel great to see you uh robert
d stewart awesome to see you thank you
for tuning in to [ __ ] yeah fridays
where we talk to real entrepreneurs
about real issues yeah exactly so we're
going to bring on our first entrepreneur
today uh kevin gould who's the founder
of glamnetics and uh would love we'll
get to hear just a tiny bit about his
story and then
what what are the challenges to do and
the whole point is supposed to be very
relevant it's like what gary and i are
seeing in the market today and and how
we can help
hey what's up guys how you doing how you
doing kevin
doing well uh i'll give you guys a quick
background my name is kevin i'm the
founder of combo ventures kind of under
combo i'm the co-founder of a few
different brands one's called glamettic
we work we work with clearbank for a
while actually we're in the eyelash
space i know there's a women's hair
brand called insert name here and then
the third is a fragrance and candle
brand that actually built with these two
influencers the dolan twins uh we'll do
you know high eight figures in revenue
this year self-funded everything so we
haven't taken on capital and figures
eight figures across the three major
brands you have yeah you know it's
really two two of them two of the bigger
ones uh glimetic and then insert name
here um we're omni channels so we're d
to c we're on over a thousand ultas just
rolled out sephora
um yeah i mean it's been it's got about
150 employees now across everything and
yeah it's been it's been a fun ride man
congratulations
thank you yeah it's obviously i'm sure
you guys are seeing it's crazy right now
with all the ios updates and everything
going on the ad space and so let me let
me jump in because i want this be
educational
yeah you know obviously you're deeper
along with a real actual business and
there's a lot of aspiring people here
uh
apple
with its ios update has really gone
heavy into privacy and and if people
think 14-5 is tough wait till they find
out what 15 has in store with email
what that's meant for kevin and a lot of
you here is the retargeting capabilities
or just and many other nuances are not
where they were over the last decade
which has a lot of direct to consumer
small and medium-sized businesses
in a in a challenge in a challenge to
be
uh better with
other best practices that don't require
an incredible strategy around media in a
facebook
instagram environment true kevin
yeah very true i mean i think what i
tell our team right is there certain
things we can't control which we can't
control the cost of facebook can't
control cpms you can optimize for it but
i mean that's out of our control so what
we really try to focus on is what are
the things that we can do as a brand
that we can control so if you're like an
early founder out there some things we
think about are you know like dms right
we look at dms as a sales prospecting
channel everyone said
like we're we're engaging in
scale scale the unscalable i always say
exactly right
everyone wants scale
yeah meanwhile
every one of you by the way who's trying
to build a personal brand or trying to
build a company you always want to find
viral and the hack meanwhile there's
comments and dms sitting there and you
have
no effort towards them you're obsessed
with acquisition and vanity metrics and
you have no care to actual relationships
and retention and that lives in dm i
agree kevin i'm devastated that i'm at
the point of my career 2007 to 2011 this
is real talk now 2007
this is actually insane i'm gonna use
this format to say it there yeah the
only reason garyvee exists
is because from 2007 only reason besides
the everybody does content
the only reason i think i was different
is because from 2007 to 2011 i replied
to every dm every email and every tweet
mentioned of me
no all of them yourself me myself i
still there's a reason there's a
teamgaryvee twitter and instagram
account i still am the person that
replies to everything when it's me that
nobody in the history of my life has
ever typed anything as garyvee ever
by the way that makes a huge difference
long term too because for us like when
we started the brands a few years ago we
replied to every single you know dm and
that fostered and built the community
right and i think the things that make a
brand defensible now against things like
changes in ios and facebook is that
community and brand factor and i think
the other thing we thought about a lot
is like we're trying to find pockets of
things where there's a gap or an
opportunity where we can jump in so
something i'm personally really bullish
on is live commerce we do 75 um facebook
lives a month between our own brand
between influencers and i think like
we're trying to get way ahead of it and
like be way ahead in building the
infrastructure but you kind of got to do
there's not one thing that can make up
for the scale of you know ads and so you
got to do you have to really do
everything right and it's really [ __ ]
hard right now so i think if you're a
founder you need to be prepared to go in
and work really hard
if you're a founder that and you know
this that over the last decade
facebook and instagram
made it math easy
yeah
right like you know by the way kevin you
know what you're going through what i
went through when email matured
i got addicted but the reason i was
there when email matured too as an
ecommerce site that had 90 percent came
through email and i remember that it was
covered
you look you're looking at two people
that went through this thing when it
happened to email right it happened now
that happened a little bit more
naturally by the consumer
um but look i mean look what let's call
what it is web 3 is staring everyone in
the face all of this is going to go to a
place where consumers have ultimate
control
we have we have people going to
non-custodial wallets people are
controlling their money
um let alone their information so it's a
very very very interesting time
um so
i i like that i like your energies and
your eyes wide open
kind of like focus
on
what um
what you're actually going into and i
think actually not being delusional
is the best way to
attack what you're about to go through
yeah for sure i mean look i think you
have to be an optimistic realist right
and and i think the other thing that i
think a lot of founders aren't as tight
on is you need to be really tight on
your numbers like we didn't raise
capital right and so
when you do go through challenges where
marketing costs rise or whatever you
need to be really tight on things the
other thing i tell the team all the time
is like there's two ways to make money
you can obviously sell more or you can
get really tight on your costs and like
find ways to whether it's packaging or
shipping or you know reducing vendor
costs there's a lot of ways to you know
run a business tight and and figure out
a way to scale it
yeah and hopefully we've been helpful in
giving you that some of that capital to
to grow and you still own the whole
thing
yeah no it's been it's been great i mean
we worked with you guys for a while now
and clear bank's been been super helpful
and
and uh yeah we haven't raised any raise
any capital outside of outside of uh
clearbank kev what um what can we answer
for you like what very narrow
or
or
any other concept like what what um
what what's like a good question to ask
like what can we answer for you yeah i
mean i think i'm i'm just here to chop
it up with whatever you what what you
think is is working now in the space
right because i'm sure you know the
brands you work with what we're doing
we're all kind of doing the same things
we're trying to get scale through tv so
that's our scale factor we just launched
tv let's start right there let's start
right there i actually think that's a
bad idea i could be wrong and i know
that every brand goes to this place let
me tell you my take on tv the remnant tv
dr move that a lot of the brands that
you grew up looking up to or a couple
years ahead were financially ahead
because of capital raise
it's interesting vaynermedia my
company's starting to really explode
because a lot of that
dtc
crew
is realizing that
tv is not performing for them
as much as they'd like for the
investment involved of course it's
performing when you spend tens if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars things
will happen
i think there's a dollar shave club
purple
mattress thing that i'm surprised so
many um
of these brands have not gone down the
path of which is the following
the long form
35 55 95
155 second video
yep
in igtv
facebook and pre-roll youtube
matching the creative and distribution
costs of remnant tv
are outperforming tv
and
you can make more contextual creative
so i guess the question i have with that
one is
have you
thought about doing a significant a b
test
or
how much effort has been put into
what i would call
brand performance
long-form video
that like uh kin insurance k-i-n
we worked with them and did something
called florida man and it's florida
comma man
and that anthem three-minute video
is is
dominating in performance as a top of
the funnel to drive down cac
yep
yeah i think we're i mean we obviously
run a lot on and we should try i think
we should for sure try out some of those
formats i mean we've spent probably 30
million dollars in the last 20 months so
we spent a lot of money on acquisition
and this is this is doing this again not
by raising lots of vc money and you know
burning
business yeah we're running a business i
believe in business and so i think the
way we're looking at tv and i think the
debate's out if it's going to work or
not we're in ulta we're in sephora we've
got amazon and so we're trying to figure
out because it's a [ __ ] show right now
and attribution right so now you can't
look in platform on facebook anymore
we're trying everyone's trying to build
a new model and like how do they look at
ga where's the attribution coming from
the problem the problem is you're doing
brand right and performance and so like
first of all brand is not measurable yep
and the thing that i like about
so have you done a two-minute brand
performance video for pre-roll youtube
or facebook
we've done a we've done a youtube one
minute video
that we're running but the thing is with
with costs right now in acquisition
right it's just super high with you know
they lost all their data right so
facebook but television has no data it's
got i mean it's got a little bit with
the connected tvs and ip addresses and
it's a little bit of us having to be
really smart about the way we're looking
at data
but but the for what you're gonna find
out which is where everyone's gone
nobody wants to watch it right
we might we might be like damn we
dropped a couple hundred k you don't
care about that and by the way by the
way up front at first it's gonna work a
little something what i know let me
phrase what i believe and i have a lot
of confidence in this by looking at a
lot of stuff is
um
it's the creative
yep
it's all hand created oh creative you
know this and the creative flexibility
you have
on doing an amazon fire stick execution
or a pre-roll youtube they don't have
the data but they have enough data to
give you some level it's not like you
have first party retargeting data 100
100 100 i mean but i kind of look at it
like influencers right like if you look
at cost in the space
facebook and youtube everything's going
up influencer costs have basically
stayed flat so we're like okay we'll
invest in influencer there's a we can
see direct through discount codes you're
never going to get back to like more
than a one to one but then there's a
there's a halo effect you hit him
yeah i mean kev honestly the biggest
mistake that brands and companies like
you historically make is
they don't take into account the
collateral impact of the spend right
well if i do something with an
influencer i don't give a [ __ ] about how
let me phrase i do care about how they
perform back to your one-to-one
conversation but i'm getting their
endorsement
for sure that's what i mean so if we can
get back to close to one to one but then
we're getting the halo and we're getting
the retargeting and more people in the
funnel but this is why i want you to
really take this episode and come back
and say
are we pushing the envelope to go viral
creatively like a purple mattress video
or a dollar shave club because once you
you have to understand there's no shot
on tv you're gonna have this but you do
have the chance to make a video that's a
minute 47 if you actually try to make it
not with performance of mine with can i
get every human on the internet for 48
hours to share this [ __ ] video
make that that part makes sense totally
makes sense i agree that's where i think
the branding
go what you know what how i think about
it kev i apologize michelle last point
it's like going one for four with a home
run
yep yeah right like
i'd rather you spend 200k four times
on a
dollar shave club attempt
like we we had it happened with dwyane
wade and budweiser a couple years ago
when he retired we did this video
where like he was retiring his jerseys
with like real people that he interacted
with in his career
and it completely like changed
budweiser's a massive brand it's hard to
sell more budweiser
i think that
your dna actually from performance and
social
lends itself
to having ingredients that are required
to make a video
that all of us lose our mind about
and share but you have to go for it
and what happens is brands go for
remnant performance based tbc to do it
and i think that's the opportunity for
you to think about
makes sense makes sense
awesome well good luck kevin i had one
more question on social selling but i
think we're almost out of time here so
we're going to uh
oh no go ahead it sounds like we're out
of time
no it's okay we'll we're going to give a
30 i want a 30 second answer from you so
you've really used influencers and how
the lives and social selling worked and
any tips for other founders out there on
that yeah i think i think you need to
build the infrastructure and the team
and need to start small so i'd set a
goal if you're a new company and try to
do five you know facebook or instagram
lives a month go find influencers that
are micro influencers that are really
good at educating the audience because i
think live selling is an amazing
opportunity to educate um and you know
you got to kind of test out and figure
out which influencers work and then just
build the infrastructure from there
brother what about what about twitch and
then finally one last point have you
thought about launching an nft project
where the token is actually a
subscription to a yearly subscription
pass
i love what the hundreds did with that i
think they they like nailed this sort of
like they basically turn it into a
loyalty program i'm definitely thinking
through it but i feel like i'm in the
exploratory
need to understand the space a little
bit more phase before i figure out let
me you know
let me
give you the boost that i gave bobby and
ben when we talked in february
which led to that project
you need to get really [ __ ] serious
about the exploratory yeah whatever
you're going to do tomorrow
well it's more saturday i don't want to
take your weekends but i'm sure at this
stage of your career
that plays as well but let's push it to
monday
you need to allocate an hour a day
to web three
because you're way too young first of
all so it's going to impact your whole
life second of all i'm completely
convinced i sold over a million copies
of my book that's coming out in november
by creating an airdrop of a token for
everybody who bought 12 copies to give
you context the single most successful
non-fiction book first week sales of all
time is barack obama and he sold 1.7
million in week one i sold
over a million in 24 hours
because of the conjunction we are in a
hyper moment of nft right now that will
ebb and flow
if you create a meaningful project and
you plenty of emails and to like give
promotion to this where by buying the
nft it also triggers a discount to a
subscription of your core product but
they know that they have an inherent
value in the nft as well i think there's
something there for you to think about i
agree what's interesting too is last
point is my co-founder ann is actually
her previous career was an artist so
we've been really toying with the idea
now now you're making me throw up now
i'm really focused now now i'm like
definitely teeth it's definitely teed up
to to do please please use this please
use the serendipity this is a triple
extra push
i appreciate it it's good to chat with
you guys i know you gotta
yeah i know we got it we gotta hop to
the next thank you for being here kevin
all right see you guys later
bye okay
so our next segment on advice of the
week is to bring back uh bobby and
brianna britton co-founders of o
positive and flow vitamins
hey
hey here michelle thanks for having us
on yeah um
we're co-founders of o-positive our
parent brand flow vitamins is the first
ever gummy vitamin for pms uh and we're
developing other products in the
feminine health space to hopefully
change uh the way inner people interact
with their with their health and and
take vitamins forever um so excited to
ask some questions uh we have quite a
bit i'll look brianna and you guys are
crushing it so congrats on like thank
you
what's
so our first question um obviously we're
a pms gummy vitamin so
um it kind of runs that fine line
between being a fun brand that is really
focused on women and also being a
scientific authority in the female space
so i wanted to ask how you guys
recommend kind of riding that line
finding the perfect balance and also
which avenue you think holds more weight
going the scientific route or more of
the brand route
i'm obsessed with the word and versus or
and i'm obsessed with
people
not debating things in board rooms that
normal human beings don't care about
yeah so you know so my hands my quick
answer to this is
whatever the woman on the other side or
the person that may influence the woman
that will use the product whether
they're passionate about the
scientific or passionate about you
taking an important subject matter and
giving it a little more breathing room
where it's not so serious and intense
you should not make the decision for the
consumer you should go both hard on both
they both play
you know they both play they
historically both play
but on the other side there's humans
that will go more for one or the other
or love the fact that it's both and i
don't think you take your pedal your
foot off either pedal and you just keep
pushing and pushing and pushing both
narratives because they're both true
like like you you can be funny
and very mathematically smart you can
right you can be ambitious
i'm a living contradiction i am wildly
ambitious
and extraordinarily patient and that
[ __ ] with people's brains
i don't i don't think there is any rules
and i think that people especially when
they go with a student mentality try to
create rules when the consumer on the
other side doesn't have them
yeah
it probably
i was just gonna say it probably funnels
really well into something more long
form when you're thinking tactically
when you're talking about a a
long form kind of purple pillow video i
mean that's both brand and science how
would you kind of go about that is that
kind of a strong avenue to both balance
brand and have the time to explain the
brand but also have the time to explain
really the science between hormones and
how these herbs ingredients and how
those all kind of tie in together
yeah i think the other thing that i
would add is i sometimes found founders
get really precious about their brand
and they like are like this is it and i
don't want to test like this is one of
those things that you like maybe test
the [ __ ] out for yeah that stuff is more
scientific you have stuff that's way
more fun and playful and then as gary
said you end up seeing how these
audiences segment but like just don't be
too precious around like oh well if we
do this it's going to somehow ruin the
brand like a brand is like it's like a
person it grows it changes your times
and it evolves and
and most of all and most of all like a
person it's dramatically resilient and
it's like parenting parents in today's
world are way too into their kids [ __ ]
which is creating anxiety
yeah and i think
business owners are over analyzing
missteps i can't explain to you
how many mistakes vaynerx makes a day
an hour
and i think that people are crippled by
right
instead of understanding it's all just
actually a process yeah and learning
yeah yeah absolutely i mean it's the
essence of what you built like if i
asked you
is this about science or fun you know
brand like a little bit more fun taking
some of the steam out of it the answer
is both i know yeah you're right it is
so why so why are we picking all of a
sudden yeah
people this is what's going on in nft
land they're like all these are people
like this [ __ ] sucks i'm like why
does it have to suck it's not coming out
of you the people don't understand the
world is inherently abundant
yeah and you have a lot of customers and
there's three ways they're gonna look at
it all science all fun loving the fact
that it's both love your triangle love
your triangle it's all three yeah yeah
that's great
i think the next question maybe is more
around content right and and producing
content i think
a facebook ad used to have a life of
weeks and months sometimes and would
grow the company for that entire time
and now you're looking at things like
tick tock where an ad might have the
life of three days and they burn out so
quickly only because people don't know
how to run those ads the difference is
the facebook ad was performance with
advancement heavily predicated on math
with art tick tock is art art art but if
you take a viral tick tock
and you turn it an organic viral tick
tock so tick-tock to me is go heavy on
organic four times a day yeah take
something that went viral which means it
hit the tonality that people were
looking for and then refurbish that into
an ad call it like brand performance
yeah
and then run that i think you can get
much more longevity than you think and
who are the people to make that who is
the ideal is it native creators is it
people on your team like how do you seek
out and find this talent
yeah by the way by the way you just
answered both yeah
you know the answers bobby yes it is
it's influencers it's an internal team
it's it's why i built vaynermedia where
we do very well with that with fortune
500 it's why i built a sasha group
because i needed to do it well for your
size companies not just budweiser and
you know um
i think it should be something you
always build internally i think it's
always good to work with external if the
people really know what they're doing as
kind of like a lease with like i always
tell my clients i'm like i'm here for 24
months not 24 years
if we do what we're doing well it will
become so ingrained in you you'll
understand it and then you'll decide
[ __ ] it we're going to build this
ourselves and that doesn't bother me
that excites me yeah yeah 100 percent
fish yeah but you're right
you're competing against again these
native creators so you're almost like
bring them into your circle right have
them help you learn the platform and
create things like that platform right
and and by the way this is where
everyone's getting caught you're not
competing with them yeah
like let me let me explain there's an
abundance of there's an abundance of
attention yes karen might go crazy and
get very big kim kardashian is quite
famous
ready for this kim kardashian has not
put anybody out of business
yeah yeah you have to go there like yes
it's great that these 47 girls are
promoting your competitors product it
still means nothing in the end of the
day because there's another 4 700 of
them right behind it
i think one of the keys to tick tock
though is that
people relate to them
and the authenticity of it so i think
the the posts that go viral are the ones
that are so authentic and so genuine and
i would say
i would say that there's unlimited posts
because of this in my life going viral
and succeeding that are that are
contextual to the platform not
necessarily authentic
okay got it don't mix up contextually
contextually strategic versus authentic
because when you think it's authentic
you two go into a place over dinner
saying [ __ ]
you know if we pay them it's not gonna
be authentic and then it's not gonna
work where in reality what's happening
is
the reason a lot of people are not
winning on tick tock is they don't know
how to make content for tick tock but if
you make content for tick tock
that is actually an ad or paid for
through an influencer
it always works
yeah yeah
and it's about being
content it's about being contextually
native to the platform not trying to put
not trying to put your flow bottle on a
dance and that is popping something
exactly let me give you an example
you can pick the influencer and then
tell her do whatever the [ __ ] you want
yeah they built an audience because they
know like this is where brands always
[ __ ] up they're like hey we love you
let's make michelle the influencer
michelle we love you and you're amazing
okay now you've got to at least mention
our brand three times you've got like
they get heavy-handed yeah
you control who you're gonna give money
to and then get out of the [ __ ] way
okay
and do that a hundred times see what you
like and then build from there
it's so so so true because actually the
best posts are always when i'm like this
actually i love my aura ring it's my
favorite thing i talk about it all the
time i like post my sleep they have
never paid or asked me to do that but
the moment because i've gotten all these
brand briefs and it's like
pen michelle they actually sometimes
write this script for you they say like
what you need to mention is like the
benefits and features it's like no one
gives a [ __ ] about that people actually
want to know that i use the product and
so it's like i i love that and i've seen
that so much but i'm just i'm just
adding this because it's important yeah
we have unlimited things working
that is a paid influencer thing yeah we
just don't tell them what to do
and we always win that with our clients
like i do it and i'm great and it's easy
for me but for my clients a lot of times
i can't get even though they hire us
even with me involved sometimes they
can't get there and the reality is it it
bites them in the ass and then they
adjust
you pick who you want to endorse and
then get completely out of the way which
is yeah fallacy in brand land
historically yeah it's not what they
teach you in school you know and so
that is that is what you need to think
about and then when it hit the other
thing you want to ask them for is the
ability to run ads against that yeah and
then and then more importantly you need
to do a lot of dyi your own [ __ ] and
learn
um in for infotainment style stuff
organically if it hits yeah slightly
tweak it change the copy and turn it
into an ad
yep
yep that's great
that's awesome infotainment i love that
awesome thank you so much guys those
were those were our two questions really
appreciate the time and thanks for
having us on gary great to meet you
michelle always a pleasure
awesome okay so i think gary and i have
time for a couple of audiences
a couple of audience uh q a so just tell
people to drop their comments
in uh in the chat and we can do uh one
or two other quick uh quick ones while
we're letting people drop their
questions in yeah um are you going to be
looking for them or is somebody going to
pop in or how we doing it
that's a really good question okay well
dustin or seth if you want to pop on
camera i always like breaking the wall
oh i see what they're doing they just
showed us the preview they'll put on
screen you please read it because i
can't read and then we'll jam but before
we go into questions two minutes
because you know i i've been yapping too
much and we haven't been able to tap
into the brilliance that you are what is
it give me one or two common themes
you're seeing right now you're sitting
at the top of this company that gets to
see a lot of what's working what's not
working
anything emerging that's very of the
moment that's really got your attention
oh it's a really good uh a really good
question um
i actually think the number one thing
we've seen very recently i love what you
said about nfts earlier i think there's
tons of potential there it's actually
like we're getting this like critical
mass on social selling like i haven't
seen anything that's like looked quite
that big in terms of
in terms of live in terms of the
influencers and then that that hedge
against all these other rising ad costs
and i think what you said was correct we
are heading to a world where people like
you're not even going to be able to see
my credit card transactions you're not
going to see anything about me and so
our ability to guess
is going to go away and so what that
means is that your friends which have
actually always been the best people to
sell you a product because referrals and
word of mouth and like there's a reason
we've been talking about an nps score
and what's the fine line between
that and the skeeziness of you know
where people haven't historically liked
you know the worst case worst versions
of mlm or network marketing
yeah i mean i think that uh
that this is all about authenticity and
standing behind your product right at
the end of the day you have to know that
that something is going to show up at
your door and are all of our mailboxes
are full and you're going to open
something and you're going to literally
keep it on your body and not take it off
or it's going to go right back in the
box right back into the garbage and
that's where you lose and gain all your
points whether you call that an
influencer will you call that a friend
like it it does not and
things have always fallen apart there
because it was never yeah but it's not
the money you make by getting more
people in your tree not the product you
actually sold not the product all right
so let's get some questions okay
uh i'm seeing more brands that think
about wholesale any tips on how gdc can
execute well in a wholesale retail
environment
your thoughts on that
yeah um
i'd say
honestly
this is so hard about building a startup
but you should actually
try and get to a certain scale before
you start distracting yourself so i
think the right time to be thinking at
wholesale is maybe when you're at five
million maybe when you're at 10 million
of online revenue then at least you have
your like logistics set up and you can
start thinking about that i
so many brands do wholesale way too
early and then they get very very
distracted because there's like three
sides of the houses to manage and you
have two separate supply chains um and
then you're looking for um
this is really about and the other thing
that i've seen brands do really well at
this stage is that they can negotiate
with their wholesalers and their
retailers once they have an online
presence you are at the mercy of these
retailers and they're all making you
know they're they're basically buying
your product on consignment you're gonna
have to take it back like the terms are
so bad but if you have a brand that
people want with a big social audience
that's now making a retailer cool all of
those dynamics switch upside down almost
immediately
i don't care if you don't have anything
there
i just think that you're you need to
know what is happening when you're
dancing with the devil right the
retailers have a lot of leverage and
they can really really
change the narrative of your brand
and
you know i think um
i think that the longer you can go
direct to consumer and collect that
consumer
and the the i think people go for
short-term
growth
and give up leverage the longer you
could be
without a wholesaler and without a
retailer the longer you have control
yeah
i'm gonna let you take this one gary
first how do you bring together an
influencer community when you don't have
much engagement
i'm not sure i really understand how do
you bring together an influencer
community when you don't have much
engagement
i'm not exactly sure jacob if you can do
a follow-up question but it sounds like
a kind of a chicken and egg thing like
you can only have a community when there
is engagement
it's like you know how do you get into
shape when you're not willing to do
exercise and eat well you're not so
that's how i kind of took that let's get
a follow-up on that let's keep going
on the topic of nfcs what does gary
vaynerchuk think about companies like
masterworks which are democratizing the
art industry
i haven't had a chance to look at
masterworks um so
i apologize i can't i can't speak to
that what i can tell you is companies
don't need to exist to democratize the
industry the blockchain by nature is
democratizing the industry the concept
of nfts and
decentralized servers if you know there
will be middlewares but they will need
to bring a lot of value to artists not
take huge commissions bring demand help
them sell the things that galleries
always did but with far smaller
economics
how does a construction company build
their brand oh my gosh have you not seen
the way people follow homes online i
mean it's like
you know it's it's like the same way
that you got food porn you got i think
but but i think to trevor's point
you know i agree with you but i think a
lot of that is the consumer and trevor
he's looking right for the b2b behavior
you're in the right platform right this
minute trevor i think you need to
speak to bring value to decision makers
right
the developers
you know can you make content that is
things like six things developers need
to worry about in 2022
how do you bring high value information
to the person that makes the decision on
which
construction company do they use those
people mainly live
on
linkedin
a linkedin content and media strategy is
what you need
yeah and then at the end of the day i
mean a construction company can exist on
very few customers and so that referral
network having every single one of those
projects create three more for you is
actually probably the most powerful way
to build both your company and your
brand i like that
what kind of nft product art or other
eyes that is not on the market would you
like to see the most
i mean all of it matthew you know like
we're in the beginning stages that's
like asking what websites would you like
to see in 1995
all of them right i mean i think
i think the
reality is is
in the art is unlimited so i want to see
all 7.7 billion people's opinion on what
art is to them
uh and then what we talked about earlier
the utility functions have not even
begun to start and there's so many ways
to do it and i think people need to
spend real time thinking about that you
know what does the smart contract hold
people going to buy homes in nft forum
people are going to make business
transactions people are going to give up
pieces of equity if you buy the nft
royalties there's so much so that's how
i'm thinking about it
yeah just getting started
okay uh last one what are some of the
things one should focus on when creating
content on linkedin
at the start of their entrepreneurial
journey
um
talking about what they actually know
not faking it till you make it like
actually talking about stuff you know
uh and
uh why would anybody
that sees this in this stream watch this
the world is filled with selfish content
creators we need more selfless
yeah and i i'd say the other thing is
like
at the end of the day one of the the
biggest story lines in the world is how
you build a company it is filled with
drama and downside and tears and i mean
i've been doing this my whole life and
it's like you know my life is a tv show
and and did did get to become a little
bit of that um and so sharing some of
those really vulnerable authentic
moments i think is so critical i mean
that's what people want they want to
understand at the end of the day that we
are not alone and so you know we we
build content that is exactly what gary
said that that looks selfish and looks
promotional uh and looks like i'm doing
so well i actually think you stand out
when you say like i [ __ ] things up and
like this is i made this mistake so you
don't have to um and when it's when it's
genuine and it doesn't feel over
produced i actually think that's you
know early stage companies have some of
the the craziest stories of all time and
so you have incredible content to start
out with
i agree
all right this was a lot of fun episode
one in the book so [ __ ] your friday
fridays
thank you guys all joining us for [ __ ]
yeah fridays uh because of travel
schedules we are going to be doing this
on thursday next week which is the 30th
at one o'clock eastern time so we'll get
you know uh a little bit of that could
be cold can we call it duck yeah
thursday yeah we can call [ __ ] yeah
thursdays we can do whatever um and so
if you want to apply for the show go to
clear.com
fyf um to be selected at uh at next
week's gary i had so much fun doing with
this me too i know a lot of you who are
watching in my community desperately
trying to get time together it's
impossible for me so take advantage of
it clear dot co slash fyf put in your
applications thank you thank you thank
you everybody for watching
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment and
exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you